[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on Saucon very
excited to be talking about humanizing
healthcare we have an epic guest joining
us today we have dr. Jessica sitter
hello hello thank you for coming onto
the show and I'm super excited you
initially met Ron at the JCC doing an
event there and then Ron taught me about
you and I got really excited about you
and then I looked into your work and I
got even more excited because this is
something that we haven't talked about
and that society's not really talking
about maybe more ancient cultures have
had a better rooting and feeling for how
to deal with death in a very humane way
and how but now the healthcare
infrastructure has gone very complex and
there's so much to talk about here
Jessica's itter is a ICU and palliative
care physician in Oakland at Highland
Hospital for the last ten years now
she's also the author of extreme
measures finding a better path to the
end of life she is also Hatton's the
feature in extremists which is this is
extremist extremist Janis promise is
better to pronounce extremities which is
a 26 minute 24 or 24 minute short
documentary about kind of what you're
right about in extreme measures and yeah
and so this is this is really important
pressing stuff that I guess is not being
talked about so in that's really
important to talk about so why don't we
let's start with talking about who you
are before we get to the to the these
pressing themes of the book so how did
you even get your footing in desire for
being a physician and being in health
care because you did some Stanford and
some Harvard some UCSF some Berkeley and
that's a lot of awesome
to go through to get to where your eyes
well by the time I got to that round of
going to those schools I had already
sort of decided I was gonna be a doctor
I decided I was gonna be a doctor when I
was kind of a baby I came I was born
into a family it was a family business
really my family was a bunch of
immigrants and very quickly once
reaching Canada which is where I was I'm
from Montreal the both sides of my
family you know immediately started
producing doctors this was like
something that was very much a part of
our family culture maybe a part of our
religious culture it was sort of this
very venerated profession and I had all
these role models of mostly men who were
very intense surgeons and running you
know er's and and different kinds of
very interventionalists types of doctors
who had kind of grown up in this time of
specialization within the healthcare
system which really started in the 60s
you know that's when we started
specializing medicine and so I decided
that the way that I could be useful in
the world was to follow in their path
and to learn how to use a variety of
different technologies and machines to
really keep people alive and to take
care of them that way so I went in to
this very intensive training sequence at
these schools and kind of in these
programs and came out the other end as a
pulmonary and critical care doctor and
that's how I ended up in medicine you
your failed that was so funny you're
describing your family like they're like
pumping out like doctors like that's so
interesting that we would have really
strong like a family that's has a really
strong like kind of like values and
mission that they know what they are
doing in the world but then the kids
kind of are more easily able to I guess
find something that they want to do
versus parenting that is a little bit
more
like well whatever code true it was so
much easier for me than a lot of my
friends because I just sort of came out
into this path and I actually remember
you know after college few years after
call just watching some of my friends
who'd been in the liberal arts and who
were kind of like trying to figure their
and I was just like I got my beeper on
my pocket and I'm going and it was it
was kind of an easy I I'm I mean I don't
say that proudly it was kind of an easy
straight ahead path and it's brought you
lots of meaning in life and that's
really important well you know I think
it brought me meeting mostly once I
started to make it mine I initially went
into this with an idea of what I was
supposed to do and the health care
medical training experience was very
happy to tell me I thought I was
supposed to be this sort of high
intensity physician and there's many
quick and there's paths to doing that
that are very easily taught protocols
and you know learning how to do
different kinds of technologies and
treatments and catheters and all that
stuff so I just got sucked into that
whole training path the meaning came
once I started to step back and say okay
now I'm doing this and how do I want to
make this something that feels better to
me because I was starting to experience
some moral distress in the way that I
was practicing medicine
yes protocol eyes approach yes so you
you just laid it out right there so
there's this protocol eyes approach and
we've heard we've had doctors talking to
us before about going off protocol and
being able to do things in a way that
actually helps with either the morals of
the patient or it said there's so many
different ways to talk about this but
you specifically I see you you actually
actually what the statistic in the book
is quite I think quite high is it was it
40 percent of deaths occur in the ICU at
the peak in like the 80s and 90s then
yeah then and that numbers gone down I
think the most recent data shows that 30
percent of people die either in an ICU
or
having recently been discharged from an
icy okay okay 30 so that's a lot that's
almost a third if people are dying in
like an icy nicey user right afterward
in that site whoa so what that's and
what you've been dealing with in that
case and I want you to explain what
palliative care is but just that there
is a lot of people that are without
their family without people that you
know love them right there when they're
in ICU that they're having some sort of
stress about what do I need to do with
the medical system what options are
there right yes they're telling you so
you know what you're talking I am in no
way throwing technology under the bus I
am NOT throwing ice use under the bus I
have many of my colleagues we have saved
many a life using these technologies and
sent people back home to their families
and there is nothing sweeter than that
that is one of the beautiful things
about the our modern health care system
the problem is that that there's there's
several reasons why we're not only
taking people who can benefit from it
but we're sweeping everybody into it and
when when you take people who are not
really going to have that kind of
benefit of a recovery and going home and
you take everybody even you know the
frail the elderly the terminally ill the
dying and you still do that same
treatment to them I call that the
end-of-life conveyor belt because what
it is is this this churning protocol
eyes literally conveyor belt that just
takes everybody indiscriminately and
does the same things to them the same
support of organs as they start to fail
as you would with somebody who really
could potentially then recover but
you're doing this to people who won't
recover and we do it we that's what
caused me this distress was I realized
subconsciously it wasn't even like I had
words in the beginning that we were
taking so many people who I knew weren't
going to benefit from this type of
treatment and doing these things to them
which really as you alluded to can cause
tremendous suffering because what it
means to be attached to machines
is several things number one you've got
machines going into your mouth
you can't talk you've got your arms tied
down frequently because we can't have
you pulling these things out so people
are lying there in bed on their backs
games in their mouths with their arms
tied down you've you're kind of sedated
you may be in pain we don't necessarily
know if you're in pain so there's a sort
of haze of possibly depends again on who
you are and what's going on but of pain
and slight mild delirium which is very
confusing and and distressing and most
importantly as you said the family the
whole structure from which you came is
not there you're in this very foreign
sterile place your family's kind of even
if they are in the room they're kind of
back there afraid you know you're coming
in you're gonna touch all these
different tubes you sort of stay away so
it's a very isolating experience and
that is I think part of the reason that
so many people are dying badly in this
country mm-hmm Wow yeah and there's this
whole idea of a good death and we'll get
to that I want I want you started he's
really started talking about all the
variables that are going into the
equation of like an oven of a human
experience inside of an ICU in this in
this case with family twos the delirium
that's coming into potentially sedated
this there's so much that that is there
and then there's this whole like
end-of-life conveyor belt okay tell us
about palliative care because yeah this
was quite interesting for me to learn
about okay well so I'll give you a
little background okay you know and I
talk about this a lot in my book because
it feels like you know that movie was it
Zelig well Forrest Gump and Zelig where
there's this person who like finds
themselves in places that were kind of
like turning points in a movement and
and that's what I kind of when I was
writing my book felt happened to me in
1996 a big study came out and I by the
way had just finished my pulmonary
fellowship the study came out was called
the support trial and it looked at how
people die in America
and it was a shock to the people who are
conducting this study was a huge study 5
centers in America and the reason I say
was a Zelig a moment for me was because
this study had been conducted during
medicals my medical school years and one
of the Centers that conducted it was
Case Western where I went to medical
school and in fact one of the the head
person of that site was dr. Albert
Alfred Connors who is my ICU attending
mentor the person who taught me about
ICU and I was in medical school so he
was conducting this study to understand
how are people dying in America with
other five other centers in the United
States the study wasn't published until
several years later 1996 when I was
already finishing up my fellowship in
pulmonary in critical care but what the
study showed was an alarming state of
how people are dying in America huge
percentage of people again dying on
machines who probably wouldn't were not
ever going to be helped by those
machines a huge percentage of people
whose preferences if they had had them
were not known by their physician the
sort of clear lack of communication
between physician that was very alarming
a lot of pain etc the second phase of
that trial
that's crucial those dying preferences
are crucial crucial I think that I can't
remember the statistics right now but I
think 31 I'm not gonna even talk about
them cuz I'll mess it up but very few
people who had preferences had this had
been information that their physicians
knew so they did a second part to the
trial the first part was observational
what's going on what's the state and as
I said the state was not good the second
part was okay let's figure out an
intervention where we can come to the
physicians we can provide enhance the
communication we'll provide information
from the patient and family to the
physician from the physician back to the
patient and family will enhance
communication etc no change no
improvement very very disturbing and
even though this wasn't the etiology or
the reason that the palliative care
movement started to rise I'm sure it was
a big factor because people started to
say
Wow people are really dying badly in
America so the palliative care movement
started I'd say I mean people will
disagree with me but it was the early
2000s that they really started putting
money into studying this Robert Wood
Johnson Foundation started giving grants
to sort of study this new approach which
is palliative care and actually before
we go into that let me tell you what
palliative care is yes to pal palliative
care comes from the word poly RA in
Latin poly re means to cloak and you can
sort of imagine this person this sick
person this patient there's somebody
coming and cloaking them sort of caring
for them attending to everything that
might be frightening them scaring them
causing distress yeah
and so the palliative care approach
which kind of came from the hospice
movement which had been started by in
the in the in the 80s by Dame Cicely
Saunders in England this sort of modern
hospice approach to bring this
multidisciplinary approach to caring for
patients from us thinking about the
social variables thinking about all of
the things that a nurse might think
about thinking about the things that a
chaplain the spiritual suffering which
is something we don't even think about
in the hospital we don't even consider
that we keep religion away that's not
real medicine so we you know and of
course physician the the management of
the symptoms finding with the infinite
is actually so crucial in the process of
well let me just give you a quick
statistic about that because I just did
a talk about the faith issue I I'm
Jewish but and I you know I'm sort of
agnostic in the way many many of us are
I don't feel comfortable praying at the
bedside with my patients and there are a
lot of my patients in a public hospital
in Oakland California are are Christian
african-american very communal prayers
and so a lot of the praying that white
might go on in a hospital like mine is
very communal and and
and loud and and and active and it's not
something that I feel like I know how to
do I certainly don't you know feel
skilled in it and I also feel like well
that's not really mine to do and most
importantly as a doctor and the way our
culture works we sort of feel like
that's supposed to be separate like if
we get into anything that has to looks
like faith it's sort of like it
diminishes us is the way we are thinking
we are supposed to keep science and
faith separate and so I never thought
that I was needed even as I started
practicing palliative care more when
this you know when when that was needed
well that the chaplain has it and I'll
go on to the next patient and what I'm
learning science and faith are kind of
merging together more into the future
it's interesting I think it really well
because here's the data the data show
that 91% of people consider themselves
spiritual 74 percent of people affiliate
with an actual faith group and I don't
remember the number but a very large
percent of people what their physicians
would want their physicians to talk with
them and even to pray with them to but
to acknowledge their faith and it's
almost never happening and I know it
ain't wasn't happening with me and so
what I've learned is when I just stay
present and I stay with my chaplain
who's amazing in the room that means so
much to my patients that enhances our
relationship this is part of the
cloaking that's how it's it's just this
multi this inter we call trans in turf
interprofessional cloaking of a patient
where we all work together on a team
that's so different from what I
experienced in the intensive care unit
where it's very hierarchical the doctors
up here no one's really you know the
doctors making all the decisions
whatever else is happening sort of
happening in an ancillary way yeah yeah
and it's it's not and I'll tell you it's
um remind me to tell you a couple of
examples of that I can give you example
after example but how it really hurts
not only the patient but it hurts all
the healthcare practitioners
and and and takes again the humanity
sucks the humanity out of the experience
of caring for people but anyway that's
what the palliative care movement was
and it was sort of growing in the 80s
the 90s and 96 the support trial and
then early 2000s Robert late 90s
different kinds of groups especially the
Robert Wood Johnson Foundation started
giving money to try to enhance the types
of interventions that palliative care
teams do in different environments so
there was a grant called enhancing
communication in the intensive care unit
and it came out from the night it was a
call for proposals in 2002 Robert Wood
Johnson Foundation for hospitals won
that grant one of them a chance happened
to be one that I had just started
working at in Newark New Jersey two
months before and I was a new ICU
attending Newark New Jersey in this
hospital and all of a sudden they had
won this grand I don't even know about
the grant yet but all of a sudden these
people start showing up in the ICU
called the family support team because
now I know at your seat no one knows
what palliative care is every support
the family support team I was like well
who are these people that they're
talking to my patients there they'd come
up to me and say hey dude I don't think
that family understands that prognosis
and I was like who are these people
that's fun that's a great first comment
to say it's like does the family even
get what's going on well they were i but
I was annoyed I was like hey my patient
you know I can handle this I'm a good
communicator I'm compassionate and then
I had my epiphany moment so I'd been
working there about I don't know eight
months nine months and this nurse who
ran the family support team Pat Murphy
she says to me when I'm one day I'm
putting in this catheter into a dying
patient and I know this patient's dying
and she's standing in the doorway and I
look up and I see her and I'm like down
and my gloves and I'm about to put this
thing this woman's Moaning under the
bedsheet and I'm putting his huge
catheter in her neck she's Pat stands at
the doorway
and she goes like this called the police
they're torturing a patient in the ICU
the nurses were there the medical
student was there everybody's around and
I was like what me torturing somebody
I'm just trying to do my job anyway what
an interesting perspective on when a
patient is basically dying there at
their last moments there's no there's
not that faith that family that those
things that the PERT that of dying
preferences are not there it's just like
jamming of more of the conveyor belt of
medical devices and things to try and
get nanoseconds more and not even asking
her you know what you know what
permission I got I got permission from
her husband who by the way I had sent
off to the waiting room so he was away
from her for these two hours which were
two out of maybe another 16 hours that
she would be on this earth telling him
we're gonna do this because it will do
this and it will help in this way and
he's like okay okay think you were gonna
help I you know she died the next day I
knew you know really I knew she was
coming to the end didn't even tell him
that there was a chance this wouldn't do
anything there was a big chance it
wouldn't do anything and didn't give him
really the option because he's a good
husband he wants to help and if the
doctors suggesting this next thing what
husband's gonna say no Wow so that was
an epiphany and and then so that is so
interesting that you ended up being
right there when the grant was made
crazy and then then you were right there
with the palliative care kind of
movement crazy forward early stages
because it didn't get become a
subspecialty in medicine until 2008 so
this was 2003 as many years beforehand
and I feel so lucky I mean I at first
was really like defensive and you know
wait a minute and and but that moment
cuz I had been feeling this sort of
distress building and when that happened
it took me a few days I got angry at
first and then and then I went up to Pat
I wait I remember I walked into her
office and I said you know what
teach me see your teeth for your right
me what to do yeah and that's when I
said okay so my mentor people say to me
who you high five
that's who are your biggest mentors a
nurse and a chaplain yes so the fact
that you had the moment where you came
to your own realization that it it's the
humility it was the humility I love that
I think it's so crucial that more of us
realize that hey somebody else that has
a different perspective on the situation
can actually help make these situations
across the world better for us together
that's beautiful and when you can
actually like anything like with any
humility in life the humility of
learning that you weren't a great parent
in this moment which I learned a lot
unfortunately and try to you know
humility actually once you can just let
it be and say okay you know what
I didn't do a great job I didn't do a
great job there it's such a relief such
a relief and it opens you up to
something so much more powerful and I've
had many many many many many many
moments of humility and I think it's one
of my biggest teachers I'm just writing
an article that's going in about I call
it putting my it's called putting my
patients in front of my ego but it's oh
interesting it it's talking about how
even as a palliative care doctor I have
to admit I still feel like I'm supposed
to be the most important person in the
room as the doctor and I'm learning that
I'm not the patient is and they're dying
patient is the first yeah but a lot of
times the chaplain has so much more to
offer than I do and you know what I need
to just sit there and witness I'm not
used to that I'm not used to that and
I'm learning how important it is and and
I feel really grateful for it but it's
so it's a it's a very different you know
different way from how I was trained and
and anyway I feel the world opening up a
little bit
you're learning
is becoming our learning it's so
fascinating because we get to live
through you through your experiences in
this sense and and I'm happy that you
came to that moment of openness and now
yeah I'm imagining the way that the
chaplains interacting with the patient
and the patient kind of like almost
drops into their their body in this in
the spirit and the infant more than
potentially being like okay we're gonna
give you a couple more hours this way
wow there's so much to talk about so
okay so then over the last like ten
years has been kind of this developing
out of the human you know the humility
getting more and more doctors to be
working with this more disciplines of of
people that can help actually tend to
the patient's needs first the palliative
care whatever it is that the patient
needs finding out what the patient needs
finding out where the most suffering is
whether I'm the ICU attending or the
palliative care attending it's always
about the patient and eliciting from
them what they need what they need to
know what they want to know and how we
can help them achieve what's most
important to them yeah yeah so then okay
so then through this this 10-year period
so did Highland to get also did you kind
of bring palliative care too high no I
mean I don't know yeah tell me about how
look that period work before we get six
treat yourself well palliative care has
been growing now you know in fact
there's a I mean the movement has it's
fascinating actually really it's it's
it's it's captured in some ways I think
it's captured the imagination of many in
the non-medical community saying wow I I
didn't know theft could be so bad
because it's we're starting to talk
about it more even in the lay press and
people are starting to say whoa wait a
minute so this is that many grassroots
movements are born from the non you know
from from the grassroots so we're
hearing a lot of we're having a lot more
kind of activity and movement in the out
there in the non medical community
saying wait a minute I know
I don't want this to be my only option
and then within the medical community
there's so many people like me so many
people who just needed a little
something to wake them up to say yeah I
don't I don't want to be working like
that as an automaton I do care about my
patients and want to be connecting in a
humanistic way the vast majority of
people who go into medicine are really
good people and people I work with are
fantastic and giving you give them one
little alternate route alternate
approach and they want it just like I
did and what we're finding at Highland
is that it's just been amazing just in
the past even the past year we have
watched our consult numbers rise rapidly
and what's interesting there is that you
know you're seeing this called culture
change within the within the healthcare
world if for a while people were like
you know what that kind of stuff like I
used to think if I just had more time I
would do it I'll get to it I'll get to
that conversation with a patient all I
am carrying I am compassionate but I
think what people are starting to
realize is number one I don't have the
time so I do need some support from the
palliative care division number two I
need some spiritual support I need some
social support so let's pull in
palliative care and also less from the
practical perspective of I need these
types of things that the palliative care
community group can do I think there's
also just this this incredible sense of
wow there is so much suffering at the
end of life and I don't want to do this
alone
so what what we you know have to figure
out and as a movement in palliative care
is is how are we going to how are we
going to leverage our presence we can't
have enough palliative care doctors to
attend to all of the suffering that's
happening what we can do is we can teach
other doctors like I was taught by Pat
how to do some of this work themselves
how to do some elicitation of
preferences and values from patients
which we never really learned how to do
formally how to do some matching of
preferences and values with what we're
going to do next in terms of medical
decision making how to manage pain
because pain is a very big problem
people are dying in pain at very large
numbers and I mean I didn't I wasn't
really taught a huge amount about
managing pain for me in the ICU the
whole goal was keep the blood pressure
up and let me tell you something pain
and sedation medications lower the blood
pressure there were many times I'm
embarrassed to tell you where I didn't
even think about treating pain in a
patient who was dying I thought about
keeping their blood pressure up
primarily that's not that's not okay and
so we're we can spread that information
out to other practitioners so that a lot
of what they're coming to us for right
now that's causing us to just honestly
not be able to keep up with the workload
is stuff that we can have them do what's
called primary palliative care
palliative care that's delivered by the
primary team not by us that we're more
specialty palliative care interesting
now this seems as though it's been going
on actually in different capacities for
like thousands of years and then it's
just interesting that now the West kind
of in some ways a mess some things
oh you perfectly yes it's exactly right
do you want to know the history of how
we messed it up in the West I would like
to know that and I want to also tell you
that I think that a lot of people would
actually probably prefer if they were
only had like a day or whatnot left I
would love to go and die in the middle
of muir woods or on Stinson Beach or
something like that like I would like
amongst people with family and whatnot
but me laying there amongst the trees
and animals and Beach and water and not
in a hospital you know most people agree
with you and the problem is you know we
have those data that shows you know 80%
of people say they would want to die at
home oh yes which is not happening I
mean at this point the numbers the most
recent numbers are 40% of people are
dying at home but that's even an over
estimate because
of that 40% there's a huge number of
what we're calling an a rising number of
something that's called burdensome
transitions which means people are
getting home but right before they die
from the hospital so that 40% is an over
estimate people are not dying the way
they would like to die now the fact that
you would like to die in muir woods is
great information somewhere ain't
perfect it's dying preferences you have
to ask people I don't want even the
medical world shouldn't be asking you
you should be thinking this guy's death
consciousness exactly we are so we're
pretending we're never gonna die like
having about like our own dying
preferences note with our own tenant
like what we care we want to do the
Buddhists say deafs I'm gonna butcher
this but death should always be on your
shoulder we have a service that we use
called we croak that sends us daily
death quotes oh yeah it's so good in
that way what's what's the quote right
now what does it say I see he's on his
yes it's
kurgan croak says whatever you're meant
to do do it now the conditions are
always impossible hmm there you go well
the fact is I was just speaking with
Frank hasta cesky who's you know the
founder of Zen hospice an amazing man a
Buddhist we're gonna actually be in
conversation soon in April I'm really
excited maybe we should have him on some
kind that be great very smart guy and he
said that you know having an awareness
of death is what lets you live your life
better and I agree with that so true
you know we probe the Greece but you
know okay you pray he also said and I
totally agree with him that so much of
this movement that's really arisen in
the past few years but this interest
this grassroots interest in death and
making death sort of an amazing
experience is is complicated because you
know it puts too much pressure on that
moment you're focusing so much on that
moment so at that moment doesn't quite
go
the way you want it to that could be
seen as a big failure the real focus
should be on how is this neither living
all those days leading up to that that
moment you want to do everything you can
to make it it consistent with your goals
it would be great if you could die in
muir woods you know you might not be
able to die in there and you know as I
said I've seen many stories of people
doing everything perfectly bringing in
hospice at the right time having this
incredible supportive family in place
having a great community you know
community faith community that comes and
checks on them and plays guitar and all
that stuff and the fact is that that
doesn't always guarantee a good death
either so it cannot just be focused on
how do you make that moment of death so
great it has to really be you know yes
you want to try to enhance that but like
putting all the other stuff in place
during your life that's what this is
right now
yeah and that's where we find a lot of
our meaning in life is by putting the
right pieces together that we care about
that leads us to the most meaning in our
lives okay
now that this this has been a super
solid I want to see when we can get to
with some of the I was gonna tell you
hello I was gonna tell you how we
screwed it up that's tell us to screw up
yeah it's actually fascinating okay I do
a talk that's called all that glitters
and it's about it's about the rise of
the intensive care unit mm-hmm with all
of its other associated what are they
called condiments
the condiments multi-thousand dollar add
ons the add-ons right the siloing of
healthcare the hyper focusing that
started to happen in the 1930s do you
remember that what you're young but you
know the heart-lung machine the iron
lung
did you ever see pictures of that that
sounds somewhat familiar
the iron lung machine saved I don't know
tens or hundreds of I think hundreds of
thousands of people from dying from
polio in the polio outbreak of the late
20s and early 30s and 40s and 50s crazy
yeah a negative pressure ventilator also
known as iron lung or pool water so
nearly obsolete mechanical respirator
which enables person to breathe on their
own in normal manner when a muscle
control is lost Oh what so here's the
thing in the night in the 1920 in 1928
there were two got two guys excuse me
sorry about my cough okay two two guys
from the Harvard School of Public Policy
I believe the weather's or or some kind
of school at Harvard and they decided to
create a machine they literally took two
engines out of vacuum cleaners and they
use them to reverse suck air out of a
chamber and that earliest prototype kind
of sat in the base at basement at
Harvard and then when it came time in
that sort of mid 30s late 30s before the
polio epidemic to start to kick in they
started to put people into these these
chambers and the chambers basically what
suck air out so it would inflate the
lungs of a person rhythmically and ten
and I think hundreds of thousands of
patients who would have died from polio
which causes a weakening so you cannot
you can't you know the muscle strength
to breathe survived my auntie Fannie
survived and went on to live normal
lives and well how do you gain muscle
strength how does it out because polio
is a virus until once the virus kind of
got out of your body and you could
regain it was a bridge why go to bridge
I see a branch until the virus gets out
of the body okay just a bridge kept them
alive you could they had these like but
we thought we could iron lung out all of
them and we did we had huge success with
it it was unbelievable then around world
war ii and korea during those wars was
the first time that physicians
learned how to manage shock and they
could manage you know massive hemorrhage
and shock infectious shock on the
battlefield they had these shacks like
mash the movie mash you know this is the
TVA yes they would be right near the
fighting and they would go and they
would drag these people back into these
things and they would resuscitate them
what so for the first time ever in
warfare young and healthy soldiers were
resuscitated who would have died and
sent home yeah through the shock it said
that's do is that mostly through the
cardio through them well it was it was
using hemodynamic management which was
again this sort of knew his prison
principles of physic and really of
resuscitation so people are learning how
to resuscitate bodies that would have
died this was new in the mid 1900s 1958
the first intensive care unit at Johns
Hopkins was created and you know you
need room these are from these machines
by the way the iron lung gave way to the
modern mechanical ventilator which we
use now to inflate lungs now it's not
not negative pressure that's sucking
open it's positive pressure that's
pushed into ya so anyway you need room
for these things you need electricity
you need tubes that have vacuuming
because we need to use a lot of
vacuuming to suck away things you needed
a space and so the intensive care unit
was formed and that was 1958 in the next
ten years every hospital in America had
at least one intensive care unit oh
thank you
every intensive care unit had at least
one now we have now almost created this
ridiculous situation we have an
intensive care unit for every possible
thing you could want pediatric intensive
care unit the PICU neonatal intensive
care the NICU medical intensive care
unit the mick you surgical intensive
cured the sick you I just heard about
and there are a huge multitude cardiac
intensive care unit there's a digestive
diseases intensive care unit so not only
do we have intensive care unit we have
the most intricate subspecialties that
you can imagine
yeah hepatology you know various types
of all of these doctors who are now
going in a soup sub specializing yes
when I was doing my residency at the
Brigham we had 60 graduates at the end
of my residency how many of those do you
think went into primary care out of 63
and everyone else specialized now things
have changed since 1995 many more people
go into primary care but that's pretty
that's a pretty important thing to think
about these are these are this is my
generation of doctors yeah this
specialization earns more money and
there's more opportunity there's many
reasons thank you Ron
there's many reasons why you could look
you could you could wonder why people
sub-specialized and here are a few of
them people certainly make a ton more
money geriatricians family practice
doctors and primary care doctors and
palliative care doctors make the least
amount of money yes yeah okay it is
about two hundred and sixty dollars I
think you get from Medicare to do a
biopsy skin biopsy which takes about six
minutes if you want to sit and have a
conversation with somebody about
end-of-life practices and their
preferences you get paid I think it's
$78 for half an hour I mean it's it's
really discrepant yeah the things that
we're valuing in our healthcare system
financially and also in terms of
prestige are doing doing things to
people yeah we were in just in you know
there's like I think it's half of all of
the healthcare expenditures are going
towards the orphan related diseases that
are affecting such a very very
small-time amount of people versus the
and again if we valued staying healthy
and and and these these preferences the
patient preference is putting the
patient before the ego like you're
writing about right now okay let's let's
dive into we have been already touching
on a lot of the things in extreme
measures but I want you to give a kind
of like a big-picture overview tell us
about that
so the book is really it's it's it's
kind of part memoir
it's my transition story through this
this this change this change in in in my
goals you know again you know going from
being really disease focused or or an
organ focused physician to a whole human
focused physician and it tells that
story of that moment of Epiphany and
what you know a metalic Alan jizz that
exist in our healthcare system that
prevents so many of us from going
through that transition why is it so
much easier to be I'd organ focus doctor
why is it so much easier to focus on a
procedure than it is to focus on talking
to somebody and it really kind of gives
that whole story
both hopefully in for a physician
audience to sort of for us all to come
together and talk about some of these
psychological things that are happening
inside of us that keep us from doing the
things we want to do and also for the
lay community because this book was
written for both to sort of explain
what's going on to give perspective and
hopefully to empower people to
understand what the end-of-life conveyor
belt is how at-risk they are for being
swept on to it because we all are and
how important it is to empower yourself
to start to think about the things that
are important to you how you live and
how you die and make sure that those
things stay front and center throughout
your life and particularly in the health
care system yeah I liked going on your
journey and
that you also explained it to us the
journey of the prop of this through from
the early 1900's until now where things
have kind of been going and and it it
totally seems like we're integrating
back to the principles of patient first
and using the faith base and and other
end of life caring about what their
preference our preferences are you also
were teaching us about how it's so
important to have a sense a really deep
sense of empathy with a patient and have
a you know if they are asking you to
pray with them maybe acknowledge your
discomfort acknowledge your fears but I
think it's still important to do that
and to seek out figuring out what they
want from us would that will be most
helpful yes their decisions to go with
see and the certain treatments that can
sometimes be burdens actually decreases
if you get if you build a relationship
with them right and that's borne out not
only in my own experience but in the
palliative care literature that when we
do engage in communication and in a
relationship and the communication and
relationship have to be established
before you start making decisions about
do you want to be full code or not full
code or do you want to do this surgery
you have to have a relationship a
therapeutic trusting relationship with
somebody before you can really start
knowing what the right decisions are and
helping them make those decisions but
what we know is that when we do engage
in creating those kinds of relationships
patients tend to choose lower levels of
intensity of treatment at the ends of
life and they die less commonly in the
intensive care unit they tend to die
more often in hospice they tend to die
in less pain
it works it works yeah
relationships really work yeah the eye
to eye human connection asking them what
they care about what their preferences
are that that works yeah okay I want to
see what is going on with your future
where are you going moving forward with
things what are you thinking well I'm a
storyteller and a cougher Anacapa I
really I am moved by story for my own
personal growth the things that move me
are the little moments life just the
other day I was in a room in the
pulmonary clinic I was in pulmonary
clinic and I was talking to a patient
hmm he is kind of dying and I wanted to
start to talk to her about her
end-of-life preferences and and we had
the translator on the phone cuz she
spoke Cantonese and it was so it was
just such a moment like of we're sitting
here it's very hard to use a translator
on the phone to talk about these really
profound things but these uncomfortable
things and so and this translator I
would say something and somehow what he
would say would stretch out probably
eight times longer than what I would say
and and not only was I just like ah but
the family was like ah so it was this
bizarre experience and then there was
some kind of problem with his phone so
every time he'd be talking it was like
he was having he would be pressing a
button for a sec so he just baby I mean
was just a funny moment a poignant
moment of like an attempt to have a
connection with my patient and just all
of these things conspire against it and
I just felt like okay that's a moment I
have to write about but so for me
writing stories and noticing these
moments these little things that's what
that's what that's what fuels my growth
and makes me think about ways that we
can do things differently hopefully a
better one day
and I just will keep telling stories I'm
gonna be writing and writing and writing
what I also believe is that that stories
as I I think we found with the movie
extremities story and by the way that
the two main stories and extremists the
movie are also in my book you'll
recognize them if you pay attention
didn't they go in my book in much deeper
detail about those two main stories but
I really believe in sort of the power of
using story in both lay communities and
in medical communities to try to get
people to to examine themselves and try
to grow and so I've been working with a
variety of different teaching teaching
experiences that in pull in story and
use prompt questions and really try to
get people to reflect in their own sort
of minds on some of these things that
are really hard to talk about and try to
put up in the honest conversation we did
it at UCSF for their department
anesthesia and I think that this program
could be used in a whole variety of
medical training environments and now
we're starting to use it in lay
communities but I think using story to
change behavior is is really an area
that I would like to go and and creating
new films that also themselves have a
story to them and a lesson to be learned
through watching other people's
experiences we have two films that are
coming out and and a few more that I
would like to work on so well film and
then also writing and it is all based on
self awareness there's awareness
increasing about this about this field
about the subject hopefully it'll help
people to become more interested in
aware instead of just providing them
data hearing a story and saying HM
that's interesting that and and being
moved by that to start thinking
differently about it yeah that's huge
work okay me okay we like to ask a
couple questions on the way out of the
show I'm interested to hear your
thoughts about it what do you think
we're alone in the cosmos
how could we possibly be I mean I don't
the numbers just don't support that that
we'd be alone right I mean would I
really start to think about it I go
crazy but I can't imagine that there
isn't another form of intelligent of
intelligence out in the universe and you
want to talk about humility I mean I
think it's kind of know maybe this isn't
fair but I kind of think it's arrogant
to think that we'd be the only
intelligent life in the universe how can
we possibly be so I I just I guess in
some ways I do I would love to see proof
of it but what do you think hmm are you
not supposed to tell I'm not no I just
think it's very yeah it's very
complicated and interesting I mean I'm
very fascinated by what exists past the
three dimensional systems that we have
Rachel do you think we're dissimulation
hmm oh that's interesting
you mean do you think we are a
simulation by some higher power I think
it's possible I have no idea but I do
think it's possible like an experiment
uh-huh
what would what kind of nudges you in
that direction of thought well I mean as
I said I think there must be more
intelligent forms of life out in the
universe I just do think that and given
that they must know about us mm-hmm I
would think
I wish I could I wish I knew for sure
but yeah mm-hmm I don't know if we're an
actual experiment but I wouldn't be
surprised
mmm freak you to say that yeah yeah it's
fun it's fun replay button it's kind of
I don't know if we're passing by the way
if our simulation is working oh oh yeah
yeah raid we may have failed in some
areas here yeah well not we if it's an
experiment hey our family I just want to
throw that out there right you know if
it's okay yeah yeah interesting
questions the experiments item of things
in a very interesting glad you brought
that up she's the first that said that I
think experiment yeah I think so yeah
yeah we we've frequently enjoy that sort
of a the zoo hypothesis is a hypothesis
that's we are not being discussed about
until we evolve to the capacity to at
least some sort of an intelligent
capacity to unlock communication with
them like teleportation or something
like that you've seen that Saturday
Night Live skit with Kate McKinnon where
she's there talking about how she yep
you haven't seen oh my gosh it's
hilarious there's this whole series of
ones that they do where like three
people got sucked up into a some kind of
machine from outer space and had this
amazing experience the two of them they
talk about how beautiful it was and
she's talking about well I don't know
about Ariel but and she's smoking a
cigarette it's it's hilarity should
watch it was very she's just talking
about these beings from a higher planet
yeah like you know they put something up
my keister I mean she it's totally
irrelevant anything irreverent and
hilarious you should watch you would get
a cool one of my favorite kate mckinnon
series just the last question what do
you think the most beautiful thing in
the world
hmm
Wow there's so many but if I had to
reduce it to 1
it's the human ability to connect what
you know people to connect it it's just
this sense of like what happens when you
connect with other people whether
they're friends or people on the street
or your patients or your kids your
husband and you sort of get this sort of
connection of like like minds and and
not being alone in the universe
mm-hm yeah because really if you think
about it I mean that's very human well
it's not just a human thing my dog
snuggles up with me but I don't know
there's something just really profound
about about connecting with something
else and not just being this sort of
little robotic lone thing mm-hmm that
would have to be it yeah Jessica this
has been such a pleasure thank you for
coming on teaching us about all this oh
thanks for listening we're living
through your experiences and that's been
that's been very interesting to us and
to us and hopefully so many of you that
are tuning in because who would have
thought that that people on the way to
death are just not having the ideal good
death preferences that they so want you
to be willing to talk about these things
we do they can make it better we can
make it so much better yes oh my gosh
yes just a lot of low-hanging fruit out
there yes thank you Jessica thank you so
much for coming on the show greatly
appreciate it here thank you thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you give us your thoughts in
the comments below many of us may be
having this these scenarios happening to
us in our lives with our families and
our near friends so go and share with
other people about dying
Frances having good deaths etc also
thank you to Ron for producing and
directing give us your thoughts again
everyone we'd love you very much for
tuning in thank you thank you and go and
build the future manifest your destiny
into the world check out extreme
measures links in the bio also Jessica's
website links to the by our Twitter
links nevah go check all that out
everyone extremities in the bio as well
ok everyone
much love we'll see you soon build
create bye
[Music]
[Music]